he tubers is Charlie so we found out
what Mira's gonna look like in the
Justice League movie and the Aquaman
movie so let's break it down if you
thought that Aquaman was mean just wait
till you get a load of her so we finally
get to see Amber Heard in full battle
gear that's kind of how we've been
seeing Jason Momoa and all the behind
the scenes Justice League stuff like
he's always dressed as he's getting
ready to head into war with the
exception of that Batman recruitment
scene that looks like it takes place
relatively early in the movie where he's
just like wearing normal clothes then we
see him walk back out to the sea
drinking that whiskey just raising the
waves up as if he's going back to
Atlantis but thus far we haven't seen a
lot of the Aquaman movie stuff in the
Justice League stuff we've seen so far
and just to be clear
Amber Heard is going to be in Justice
League so this image is a Justice League
thing but obviously she's going to look
similar during the Aquaman movie but
just as League being a big movie about
them preparing for war obviously they're
going to be armored up for most of their
appearances we will probably see her out
of that armor in the Aquaman movie but
the thing is as most of you probably
know that mera is Aquaman's wife but
she's had a bunch of retcons across the
comics like in rebirth right now we've
only just met the new version of her
because they've kind of retcon stuff
again but she's still with Aquaman like
still very much in love and with Aquaman
but in the comics usually she's
presented as the queen of Atlantis but
she's also the queen of this penal
colony like she's actually from this
penal colony of exiled people from
Atlantis from a previous civil war so
she's one of the leaders of the people
from this prison colony trying to
honeypot Aquaman but then she ends up
falling in love with him
so the earth is about 71% water Aquaman
is king of all that so naturally you
have a lot of people that are trying to
steal from the king steal his treasure
steal his territory steal his crown so
they haven't really explained where
Aquaman's characters at when we get to
Justice League what his relationship
with his people is like but Atlanteans
are extremely xenophobic and one of the
big problems with that is that he's
half-human so it becomes this big
struggle where he tries to win them over
but technically the crown is his by
rights so it becomes this big game of
Thrones style story where you're
battling for the throne but at various
points in the
comics mirrors had like a very
contentious relationship with Aquaman
but like they always end up together
eventually but there's a story of them
losing their child to Black Manta maybe
they'll do that in the movies you know
maybe those sidestep that they've kind
of retcon that in the comics right now
and there was that period where Aquaman
got his hand chopped off I don't think
they're going to be doing that anytime
soon
so you don't really need to read a lot
of old Aquaman comics but rebirth is
actually pretty good across the board
rebirth is pretty good for all the DC
characters but typically what they do
before the big DC movies come out is
they release like very specific comics
that create the context for what the
characters are doing so you can read
that and you'll know like what's going
on specific to the movie but it is fun
to go back and read some big Aquaman
stories and if you haven't been reading
it I would recommend you check out at
least the first issue of Aquaman rebirth
just so you get a little context for
what the universe is like the issue does
a good job of giving you an idea for the
scale of Aquaman's Kingdom you know king
of 71% of the earth kind of makes him de
facto king of the earth when you really
think about it so naturally it's really
hard for him to keep up with threats and
it's a really complicated Atlantean
society that he doesn't fully understand
himself so Mira is usually the person
who helps Aquaman deal with a lot of
that so you have to imagine Aquaman
having one foot in both worlds Mira is
fully in the atlantean world so she has
to step up a lot to help him out when it
comes to Atlantean problems but you guys
have probably heard this James Wan is
making the Aquaman movie he's a very
noted horror director so the Aquaman
movie is going to have a lot of horror
in it like you think about a lot of the
horrors living in the deep oceans like
the Marianas Trench
so while DC isn't going to make an
outright horror film like it's not going
to be like a Freddy vs. Jason slasher
flick there gonna be a lot of scary
things inside it and I think that'll be
a lot of fun there just be like the
whole gamut of DC films like Aquaman's
world is so different from ours that I
just can't wait to see it in the movies
but let me know in the comments what do
you think about amber herds armor that
she's wearing it looks similar to
Aquaman's they're both wearing Atlantean
armor so if I mean of course there's
gonna be a lot of similarities but like
she usually walks around wearing the
around Aquaman typically does not wear
his crown so don't be surprised if we do
get a moment at Justice League where he
actually sits on the throne of Atlantis
and wears the crown but we don't really
know whether or not he's actually United
the seven seas so to speak if he's
United his kingdom and if he is
currently sitting on the throne because
it's all been in there like there have
been times in the comics when he's had
to take his kingdom back but don't
expect them to get super bogged down in
the politics of Atlantean society like
that's probably like the most boring
part of it but just a reminder rumor
mill is saying we'll get that first
Justice League trailer around
Christmastime so if we start seeing
teasers during November that lets you
know that yeah we're probably going to
be seeing that trailer so just be
prepared for a lot of Justice League
stuff to be dropping in December but
they've been dropping behind the scenes
stuff pretty regularly at least a couple
times a month for the last couple of
months so there's just like a couple
really big movies that we are in trailer
watch mode for we got spider-man Home
Coming guardians of the galaxy 2
obviously Marvel's dropping a couple
movies later this year so that's when
we'll probably see a lot of that stuff
so a lot of really cool stuffs going to
be happening in the next couple of
months but those easy to been asking I
am planning on doing a spider-man
homecoming video this weekend I need to
finish Luke Cage so whole bunch of
Marvel DC stuff going on and there's
been a bunch of Game of Thrones Season 7
stuff happening so I'll probably be
doing Game of Thrones either tonight or
tomorrow new flash trailer with just a
quick coming tonight while you wait for
that you can click here for that Justice
League behind the scenes trailer again
and you can click here for my flash
episode from this week thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you